dr. deborah birx is a Whitehouse
coronavirus response coordinator and
joins us now with moral in this story
dr. Burks thank you so much for joining
us I know you are very very busy these
days I want to start with the numbers
again here in New York because they're
now 730 Fillmore families who are
mourning the loss of a loved one yet
despite that devastating number there do
appear signs in New York that the virus
is slowing here the spread of the virus
is slowing what is the data showing you
all and what does that mean for other
other states well thank you for
recognizing the impact that this virus
is having on families on communities on
counties and on States and I think
really when you work on pandemics you
have to always be conscious if they're
human beings behind each one of the
numbers and so we do track the numbers
very carefully we track the numbers
because they were a reflection of what's
happening to people in the community and
so we we are beginning to see some
flattening of the number of new cases
per day in specific metro areas or
remember we we do this very granular ly
we look at the county level we
triangulate testing data with case data
with hospitalizations with ICU use and
certainly with with the deaths that are
occurring to really get a full picture
of what's happening community by
community
the CDC we're hearing is reportedly
considering easing the guidelines for
workers in critical jobs if they're
asymptomatic what can you tell us about
that I think they're going to publish it
today it's a very important piece
because it looks at degree of exposure
and really making it clear that exposure
occurs within six feet for more than 15
minutes so really understanding where
you shouldn't be within six feet of
people right now but if you're in a work
situation where you have to be there'll
be a series of recommendations that if
you had had a significant exposure of
what specifically to do and if you've
had a less exposure what to do and we
really want to we want to thank all of
our critical frontline workers the
health care workers but also the
individuals driving the trucks and
bringing food to
grocery stores and making sure that we
have the ability to have the essentials
that we need every day I would imagine
you don't want to step into this
controversy that the president
apparently has created where he's
blasted the w-h-o does he have a point
for blaming them that what he says for
spreading the virus does he have a point
you know the w-h-o can only react to the
data it's given and when you go back and
look at the timeline it wasn't until I
think almost the middle of January that
it was that China reported that there
was human to human transmission we have
to really investigate reporting and how
the reports were received there I think
it did delay the ability to declare this
a global pandemic and emergency we can
do all of that when we get through this
as a global community to really
understand how to do this better the
next time
dr. Fauci says listen we all know that
summer plants look very dicey right now
but dr. Fauci said something I think was
encouraging to a lot of parents that he
thinks schools will be able we'll be
able to go back in session in the fall
do you see that as well we're very
encouraged about you know no one has
done this kind of mitigation before and
I just want to be very clear nowhere
around the world have we done what we're
doing together as a global community and
specifically as Americans here in the
United States and we're learning every
day how to do it how to do it better
what can be done what needs to be done
all of this was theoretic until we
really started to see the impact of the
credible impact of mitigation in
California and Washington State and
beginning to see those early shoots of
success of mitigation in the large metro
areas so these are what we're learning
from will learn very also very clearly
what happens in China now that they've
opened things back up we're watching
that very closely I think we're really
better prepared both for analyzing
what's happening now and what's not
gonna happen in the future dr. deborah
birx thank you always good to see you
may we say I hope your little grin
daughter's better you talked about her
the other day with 105 fever we all gasp
with that hope she's okay thank you
about five days if that was tough but
she now has the rash so I know it's
roseola so I'm relieved thank you rash
looks good under these circumstances
Tony yes yeah that's right Gala rash
does look good it was it was nice to
hear dr. Burks they say that frontline
workers are more than just health care
workers there are all kinds of frontline
worker